is one of the most dangerous favelas in
rio de janeiro
and ezekiel gias is home
but he counts himself fortunate he
doesn't have to go far to get to work
and he loves his job managing an urban
farm in the district
morning everyone
today i'd like to ask the women to do
some weeding in these vegetable beds
here
we men will go to the beds in the back
and spread some soil where we'll be
planting okra
so are we all set
great let's go
almost 10 years ago rio's municipal
government decided to transform this
patch of land into a community garden
it's part of the city's hortas cariocas
urban agriculture program
gias never imagined he would become an
urban gardener
in 2013 i was out of work and had
nothing to keep me busy
i had no goals in life
the vegetable garden appeared at exactly
the right moment and changed my life
it changed me
today i'm a farmer something i would
never have expected
today i know what i am an urban farmer
the garden is a patch of lush green in
this poor district many people here are
out of work and gang violence is rife
the garden was planted on land where
residents used to dump trash and addicts
smoked crack
today it covers an area bigger than
three soccer fields making it the
largest community garden in latin
america
ezekiel gias and his crew grow all sorts
of vegetables all without chemical
fertilizers but it's not always easy
clashes between the police and drug
gangs sometimes stop me working whatever
i plan today needs watering tomorrow but
when there's gunfire in the area i can't
be here
the community garden also provides work
for people in the favela
some used to be members of a drug gang
that largely controls this district
i was pretty messed up
i'd gone down the wrong path in life
but today i can go out with my head held
high
i can go out with my family without
being afraid of the street of being
looked at the wrong way
some of the crew are pensioners with
little money
some are mothers with a large family to
support
around 25 gardeners are employed here in
all
the city pays them a small salary
the income is a welcome source of
stability
and so is the sense of community they
find here
going
i just lost a son and was suffering from
depression when ezekiel asked if i'd
like to work here
it helped pull me out of my depression
like therapy
i couldn't live without this garden now
it's really helped me
and when i need some food i just take it
my friends here are my second family
whatever's harvested stays in the
community in rio's low-income districts
fresh organic produce is something
special
half of the harvest is sold in the
neighborhood at a reduced rate
that's one of the guidelines of the
hortas cariocas program
look at our vegetables three for the
price of two cheaper than any
supermarket
demand is high especially now that
brazil is struggling with rising food
prices
any profits from the sales are divvied
up among the urban gardeners
they donate the other half of the
produce to people in need in the favela
that's another guiding principle behind
the project
here's some spinach for you senora
the pandemic and rampant inflation mean
that more people in the favela are going
hungry
life has grown harder here it's hard to
put food on the table
many people just have rice and beans
now they can have rice and beans with a
salad made from the vegetables they
received from us as a donation
sometimes they'll buy our produce for a
low price which also gives them a bit of
color on the table and that makes me
really happy
ezekiel
family also benefits from his work in
the garden
they have something fresh and healthy on
the table every day
gias may not earn much but he's been
able to build a house in the favela
it's his pride and joy
and he's also bought a used car
but for him the urban garden is more
than an income
it's his life's work
even at the end of the day every free
minute goes to the garden
this is the corner where i grow my
seedlings this is my life growing
vegetables it's what makes me happy i
have a green thumb squeeze it and green
blood comes out farming is everything to
me really it's a wonderful job truly
satisfying
it's given my life purpose it's a
purposeful way to live this here is
everything to me it brings my heart
peace and happiness
the urban farm has helped change the
face of manginos
ezekiel gias hopes it can serve as a
model for other communities in rio and
beyond
you